[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka guten abend
rund 53.000 gemeldeten neuinfektionen
und eine neue rekord incidents von über
bayern und sachsen verhängen härtere
einschränkungen österreich geht bereits
in einem landesweiten lockdown dazu
kommen wir im verlauf der sendung noch
blicken aber erst mal nach berlin zu
einem ritual dass man nach anderthalb
jahren pandemie erfahrung nur zu gut
kennt auftritt lka-chef wieler und
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen in
einer rollenverteilung die man auch
längst kennt nicht nur in dieser
personalbesetzung sie ist geradezu
symptomatisch
auf der einen seite ein vertreter der
wissenschaft der seit monaten das
gleiche sagt nämlich warnt vor dem was
kommt dann eben ein politiker der seine
einschätzungen immer wieder ändert alte
aussagen einkassiert und wenn
schließlich die hütte brennt irgendwie
überrascht wird dass die wissenschaft
doch mal wieder recht behalten hat aus
berlin nicole diekmann
15 ging sie los die pressekonferenz des
geschäftsführenden
bundesgesundheitsministers und des lka
präsidentin sie findet seit kurzem
wieder jede woche statt denn eigentlich
ist es zehn nach zwölf darin herrscht
einigkeit wir sind in einer nationalen
notlage die auch eine gemeinsame
nationale kraftanstrengung braucht das
ist wie bei einem tancredi auf eine
hafenmauer zuführt der tanker ist erst
mal in bewegung wenn wir sofort mit
aller kraft gegen steuern dann wird er
noch eine weile weiter fahren und die
hafenmauer vielleicht noch seitlich
rahmen er wirkt sie aber hoffentlich
nicht mehr frontal einreißen dafür aber
seien zweifellos drastischere maßnahmen
nötig und zwar sofort wir brauchen jetzt
zusätzlich eine massive kontakt
reduktion um die ausbeutung des virus zu
verlangsamen dazu gehört zb wenn möglich
zu hause bleiben
großveranstaltungen absagen personenzahl
bei kleineren veranstaltungen reduzieren
hotspots wie schlecht belüftete börsen
clubs schließen nicht mal auf die frage
nach einem möglichen leck antwortete der
noch zuständige minister mit nein also
wir sind in einer lage wo man auch wenn
das jetzt wieder an die ticker meldungen
dazu produziert wo man auch nichts
ausschließen sollte viel konkreter
nämlich sehr konkret wurde er mit blick
auf den gestern von bund und ländern
beschlossenen pflege bonus
der muss jetzt auch mal spürbar sein
also wenn man seinen 5000 euro plus für
intensivpflege kräfte der lka-präsident
wurde noch deutlicher und ließ seinem
frust freien lauf er und andere
wissenschaftler hätten immer wieder und
rechtzeitig gewarnt vergebens professor
drosten sagt er wird kein papagei ich
bin schon lange der papagei wie oft habe
ich hier gesessen und habe das immer
wieder gesagt
also
so ist es einfach ebenfalls am vormittag
verabschiedete der bundesrat das
gesetzespaket der ampel zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
einstimmig am 9 dezember wollen bund und
länder prüfen ob es reicht oder ob die
lage so dramatisch ist
die österreicher sind das schon einen
schritt weiter dramatisch ist die lage
im land schon länger doch auch die
österreichische regierung versuchte es
mit im kapellen und maßnahmen die nur
die ungeimpften einschränken sollten 3g
2g hat nicht gereicht und so muss die
regierungsparteien vp die und sebastian
kurz im sommer noch verkündet hatte man
habe die pandemie gemeistert nun genau
das tun was sie eigentlich keinesfalls
mehr wollte lockdown für alle manche
deutschen ampelkoalition er könnte da
beim blick über die grenze mulmig werden
schon immer bitter denn wunschdenken auf
realität stößt mulmig kann einem aber
erst recht werden wenn man hört dass
sich die kliniken im salzburger land
auftritt vorbereiten dagegen ist der ins
wasser fallen de winter urlaub wohl noch
das kleinere übel britta hilpert
berichtet
november ist der wellness monat heißt es
im posthotel achenkirch hier sind sie
gut vorbereitet und gebucht doch nun
muss man gerade angereisten erklären
dass es bald wieder zurück geht und es
hagelt absagen an der rezeption
bis zu 6000 nächtigungen entgehen ihn
nun so der chef denn ab montag ist
lockdown für alle wir haben eigentlich
sehr sehr positiv in die wintersaison
geblickt vor allem weil auch die
auskünfte oder die nachrichten worden es
wird keine lockdown mehr geben und schon
gar nicht für alle ist hier da jetzt
doch wieder alles anders noch am montag
wollte kanzler schallenberg einen lock
down nur für ungeimpfte das sollte den
druck erhöhen sich impfen zu lassen doch
es war zu spät für so eine langfristige
strategie die sieben tage incidents
stieg weiter rasant auf über 1000 heute
immer mehr intensivpatienten die ersten
drei teams machten sich bereit
vollbremsung heute locker und für alle
ab montag im pflicht für alle ab februar
das war ja unser ansatz die menschen
dazu zu bringen dass sie das freiwillig
machen es geht ja um die eigene
gesundheit und dass wir maßnahmen setzen
müssen im grunde genommen die grund und
freiheitsrechte extrem einstellen dass
wir jetzt auf eine impfpflicht uns
geeinigt haben zeigt dass es leider
gottes nicht ausgereicht es ist ein
eingeständnis fehlgeschlagener politik
für geimpfte sei die pandemie vorbei
sagte im sommer kanzler kurz doch
weniger als 70 prozent holten sich die
spritze ab februar ist die pflicht es
drohen verwaltungsstrafen die
impfpflicht soll verhindern was
österreich ab montag wieder erlebt alles
dicht alle zu hause weil zuviel sich
infizierten die maßnahmen jetzt kamen zu
spät deshalb sind sie noch drastischer
und bergen eine gefahr warnt der
bundespräsident heute abend die gefahr
ist groß dass die gräben jetzt noch
tiefer werden aber das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen
wir gehören zusammen wir brauchen
einander wir bedingen einander wer alle
sind doch österreich
morgen werden hier tausende impfgegner
protestieren das wird nicht nur ein
potenzielles super special event es
zeigt auch dass die späten corona
entscheidungen die spannung in der
gesellschaft verschaffen
zurück nach deutschland die luftwaffe
hält sich schon bereit um notfalls dabei
zu helfen patienten auszufliegen aus
bayern wurden intensiv patienten ja
bereits ins ausland verlegt die
bayerische landesregierung kündigte
heute mittag an die korona maßnahmen zu
verschärfen am abend zog sachsen nach
dort wird es in den hot spot sogar
nächtliche ausgangssperren geben den sie
denn tzen sind dort allerdings auch
atemberaubend in einigen landkreisen
liegen sie bei deutlich über 1000
zugleich gibt es anteilig nirgendwo mehr
ungeimpfte die kliniken haben jene
überlastung stufe erreicht ab der die
landesregierung die notbremse ziehen
muss thomas bärsch berichtet sie kamen
geschlossen zur pressekonferenz heute
abend die chefs der sächsischen kenia
koalition und ihrer fraktionen
unermüdlich hatten sie im freistaat an
verordnungen geschraubt und immer wieder
die eigenverantwortung der sachsen
betont dieses kapitel scheint nun aber
ad acta gelegt ja es gibt eine spaltung
in der gesellschaft das wissen der jetzt
auch alle aber ich finde man kann sie
auch jetzt so nicht mehr hinnehmen wir
müssen uns nicht gegenseitig alle
provozieren aber wenn jemand wider
besseren wissens wie gegen
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse gegen das
was überall auf der welt gemeinsam
konsens ist wie man agiert dinge erzählt
muss man auch wieder sprechen und sagen
so nicht das heißt aber auch konkret für
ungeimpfte wird es in sachsen zunehmend
ungemütlich das konkrete überlässt der
regierungschef der gesundheitsministerin
nur ein paar beispiele
wir haben einem thema alkohol gesagt
dass der ausschank und konsum in der
öffentlichkeit von alkohol untersagt ist
wir haben eine hotspot regelung
aufgenommen das heißt es ist eine
ausgangs beschränkung für ungeimpfte und
nicht genesene zwischen 22 und 6 uhr
geben wird körpernahe dienstleistungen
auch hier haben wir gesagt dass alle
schließen müssen eine ausnahme soll es
bei den friseuren geben die haben wir
immer in unseren verordnungen als
grundbedarf eingeordnet allerdings auch
hier mit 2g viele in sachsen haben das
kommen sehen auch thomas kleinert er hat
verständnis er weiß aber auch was es
bedeutet nämlich dass er in zukunft
seine kunden kontrollieren muss und das
konsequent allerdings denke ich das ist
sicher auch den einen oder anderen
moment geben kann und dass ein bisschen
schwierig wird weil es einfach auch
potenzielle kunden gibt die das noch
nicht registriert haben dass es so ist
außerdem rechnet thomas kleinert mit
einbußen etwa jeder dritte seiner kunden
so schätzt er ist ohne impfschutz die
politik sieht aber keinen ausweg
sachsens krankenhäuser fühlen sich in
beängstigendem tempo so gelten ab montag
auch wieder kontakt beschränkungen jeder
haushalt darf nur eine person treffen
drastisch aber von der wissenschaft
gestützt
wir haben leider jetzt das kann man an
handy mobil daten ablesen an allem ganz
andere kontakthäufigkeit also das im
dezember letzten jahres hatten bei einem
virus was heute viel infektiöser ist
sachsen zeigt sich entschlossen und
unnachgiebig auch den striezelmarkt in
der dresdner innenstadt haben die
betreiber umsonst aufgebaut die neue
verordnung gilt bis mitte dezember dann
will man weiter sehen
tja ausgangssperren in sachsen das wäre
nach dem willen der koalitionäre künftig
eigentlich gar nicht mehr möglich über
das und anderes weil wir mit einem
rechtswissenschaftler sprechen mit
professor franz meyer professor für
öffentliches recht an der universität
bielefeld guten abend herr professor
meyer spricht sie am donnerstag läuft ja
die
epidemiologische notlage aus dass neue
abgeänderte infektionsschutzgesetz
dritten kraft kann das sein dass jetzt
sachsen und bayern mit ihren neuen
maßnahmen da so auf den letzten drücker
reingehen ja das ist in der tat der
eindruck noch muss man allerdings sagen
können die länder ganz viel machen die
können auch das volle arsenal für
wellenbrecher einsetzen aber die uhr
tickt das geht alles nur noch bis
mittwoch weil am donnerstag diese
berühmte epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite endet und hab da gilt nur noch
ein eingeschränkter ein abgespeckter
maßnahmenkatalog dagegen kontakt sperren
2g 3g aber ganz viel geht dann nicht
mehr da gehen dann nicht mehr die
ausgangssperren da können nicht mehr
einzelhandel und reisen beschränkt
werden da können keine kitas geschlossen
werden großveranstaltungen also sind
jede menge verbote verboten und das ist
teil eines kompromisses das muss man
dazu sagen der auch umfasst dass das
ganze nur bis 15 zwölfter geht und von
daher ist das alles jetzt wirklich auf
den allerletzten drücker was den bayern
und in sachsen machen sie haben das sehr
deutlich kritisiert dieses beendigung
der notlage weil die eben auch damit
begründet wurde man müsse für
rechtssicherheit sorgen und da haben sie
gesagt das ist gar nicht nötig also
juristisches juristische argumentation
die die würde gar nicht so treffen
richtig ich sehe das rächt sich jetzt
argument wirklich nur als vorgeschoben
an mir scheint das ist jetzt eher mehr
rechtsunsicherheit gibt es gibt neue
begriffe in den neuen gesetz von denen
man nicht genau weiß wie sie auszulegen
sind es wird möglicherweise neue
rechtsstreitigkeiten geben und von daher
glaube ich dass das gesetz eher
verschlimmbessert worden ist man hat den
eindruck dass die feuerwehr hier teile
ihrer ausrüstung ins feuer wirft oder
vielleicht sich einfach nur eine hand
auf den rücken bindet was vielleicht
weniger dramatisch ist aber ich sehe
kein anderes land in dem man derartig
sich von vornherein der möglichkeiten
beraubt hat rechtssicherheit ist glaube
ich hier wirklich nur ein vorgeschobenes
argument das wurde ja zum beispiel auf
ein urteil des bayerischen
verwaltungsgerichtshof erwiesen der
ausgangssperren für unzulässig erklärt
hatte also das war zwar schon auch für
die fdp ein wichtiges argument zu sagen
so was darf es künftig nicht mehr
passieren
richtig das ist ein urteil das ganz
jungen erste ist das ist vom oktober
2021 aber ich glaube genau an diesem
urteil kann man ganz gut erkennen dass
das eigentlich vorgeschobene gründe sind
das ist ein urteil das handelt vom
frühjahr 2020 von vor anderthalb jahren
und das ist ein urteil das auch die
eigentlichen grundlagen dieser maßnahmen
überhaupt nicht betrifft also die
ausgangssperre die konkrete wurde für
rechtswidrig erklärt das stimmt aber
nicht weil das konzept ausgangssperre
rechtswidrig oder problematisch war
sondern die umsetzung in bayern es ging
damals wenn ich recht entsinne darum
dass man sogar einzelpersonen und
familien und personen des gleichen
haushalts verbot vor die tür zu treten
und das war dann einfach nicht
verhältnismäßig aber das instrument an
sich das wurde nicht beanstandet das
haben auch die ganzen anderen gerichte
und sind viele mittlerweile gewesen
nicht beanstandet es ist klar am ende
das sind alles vorläufige urteile sind
allerdings recht alle noch nicht
rechtskräftig kann vielleicht das
bundesverfassungsgericht ein anderes
ergebnis bringen aber da würde ich einen
kollegen zitieren da sagt die
grundrechte kommen im zweifel wieder die
toten nicht
ich wollte die toten in österreich hat
man jetzt ja einen richtigen lockdown
verhängt die haben offenbar keine
rechtsprobleme damit eine andere
konstruktion das ist ja da auf der
bundesebene angedockt so was hatten wir
auch mal kurz mit der bundes notbremse
die ist wieder außer kraft getreten aber
richtig ist österreich ist ja auch ein
zivilisierter demokratischen
verfassungsstaat und man sollte dann
eigentlich doch vermuten wenn das bei
den geht müsste das eigentlich auch bei
uns gehen und dementsprechend glaube ich
dass man insgesamt viel zu wenig auf die
nachbarn geschaut hat und versucht hat
festzustellen was hat wo anders
funktioniert das ist auch ein vorwurf
den man der gesetzgebung machen kann das
war alles sehr introvertiert
wird spannend werden was dann am 9 12
kurz bevor das auslauf trifft sich
wieder die ministerpräsidenten runde
trifft sich der bundestag was dann
eventuell für neue gesetze entwickelt
werden danke herr professor meyer vielen
dank
noch gilt dabei das alte
infektionsschutzgesetz einschließlich
der epidemischen notlage nationaler
tragweite auf der grundlage konnten die
bundesländer bisher vieles entscheiden
wenn sie wollten was prompt die frage
aufwirft warum ausgerechnet bayern so
schlecht dasteht obwohl sich der
bayerische ministerpräsident ja immer
als teamleader von team vorsicht auf
stellt für die hohen instanzen im süden
und osten der republik gibt es wohl eine
ganze reihe ursachen die für jede
landesregierung schwer zu händeln sind
auch zeigte sich in den vergangenen
wellen dass sie nicht im süden und osten
blieben sondern nach und nach über das
ganze land schwappen trotzdem hat markus
söder jetzt ein problem die pandemie die
ihnen politisch lange zeit stärkte droht
ihm jetzt zu schwächen beobachtungen
dazu von alexander pohl
markus söder scheint zu wissen welche
reaktionen ihm erwarten nach dieser
pressekonferenz von der aus er große
teile bayerns erneut in den lockdown
schicken muss die korona lage außer
kontrolle es ist auch ein déjà vu mit
einem politiker der stets an seinem
image arbeitet und der spürt dass dieses
image risse bekommt ich befürchte dass
es mehr schlaue leute gibt die eine ganz
andere idee kadetten niemals abwägt am
ende ist es immer das gleiche alle reden
durcheinander aber irgendjemand muss
entscheiden und das turnier das wir
klingt wenig nach ihm der bayerische
ministerpräsident bekannt dafür
entscheidungen allein zu treffen das
bild des machers begründet durch so dass
auftreten während der korona krise viele
hielten den csu-chef im frühsommer für
kanzlertauglich er selbst hält sich für
unverzichtbar
offenkundig hat alles was ich vorschlage
eine wirkung ich habe eine mpk gefordert
die erst abgelehnt wurde jetzt kommt
eine ich war der erste der gesagt hat
der bund muss nachschärfen jetzt
passiert dass wir hatten zu beginn der
korona pandemie tatsächlich diese
nachfrage in der bevölkerung nach den
klaren botschaften auch nach
führungspersonen davon hat söder ganz
massiv profitiert noch im oktober als
letztes bundesland öffnet bayern clubs
und diskotheken die sogenannte
krankenhaus ampel leuchtet verdächtig
lange grün das team vorsicht als dessen
lieder sich söder versteht lässt sich
wohl zu lange von niedrigen instanzen
ablenken heute liegen acht landkreise
über einer inzidenz von 1000 und bayern
mit 625 wahrscheinlich auf dem traurigen
spitzenplatz in deutschland und so
beschließt bayern einen weitgehenden
lockdown für hot spots nur schulen kitas
und supermärkte bleiben dort geöffnet
die wissenschaftler das
robert-koch-institut wir alle haben ja
immer wieder gewarnt es wird eine vierte
welle geben und wir haben die zahlen
wachsen und wachsen und wachsen sehen
und es ist relativ wenig passiert
söder der stets davor warnt die korona
krise parteipolitisch zu
instrumentalisieren
zeigt lange mit dem finger auf die ampel
in berlin ihr entwurf zum
infektionsschutzgesetz sei nicht
weitreichend genug die schuld wird
verteilt das gestolpert quasi mit kurzen
hosen und sommerreifen in einen
eiskalten winter es wird nicht
funktionieren
die csu will zwischen sich und berlin so
viel distanz wie möglich schaffen so
erklärt der csu generalsekretär
bayern zur ampel freien zone und
gegenentwurf zu berlin bayerns
finanzminister und söder vertrauter
füracker spricht von den ampel
politikern als problem tod schweiger es
wirkt wie eine konzertierte aktion gegen
gesunkenes vertrauen
im grunde ist die wahrnehmung die dass
markus söder vor allem in den
ankündigungen gut ist aber dann in der
umsetzung auch während der korona phase
eben nicht so gut ist als csu chef ist
markus söder nach wie vor unangefochten
sein ruf als macher jedoch beginnt zu
schwinden
so reden wir jetzt jedenfalls wieder
über kontakt beschränkungen lockt downs
oder wer es schon geschafft hat sich ein
muster impftermin zu organisieren wie
ein déjà vu dazu passt dass wir in
unserer sendung auch wieder einen corona
ticker haben mit kurzmeldungen zum thema
daran hansa dara hassanzadeh hat ihn
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
laut rk ii sind in den letzten 24
stunden 202 menschen an oder mit corona
verstorben die hospitalisierung rate
beträgt 5,3 im bundesweiten
wochenschnitt wird ein wert von 6 in
einem bundesland überschritten dann gilt
dort künftig die regel 2 g + test
am nächsten mittwoch sollen laut
bundesregierung 3g regeln am
arbeitsplatz gelten das heißt
beschäftigte müssen geimpft genesen oder
täglich getestet sein zeitgleich soll
auch die home office pflicht greifen
[Musik]
ab sonntag warnt das auswärtige amt vor
reisen in die niederlande und nach
belgien wegen stark steigender corona
infektionen
die italienische region lombardei bietet
deutschland an kogit intensiv patienten
aufzunehmen
das sei ein zeichen der solidarität für
die erhaltene hilfe im frühjahr 2020 als
den lombardischen städten wie bergamo
das kranken system zusammenbrach
der ungeimpfte bayern spieler joshua tmg
ist erneut in häuslicher quarantäne
aufgrund eines corona falls in seinem
umfeld frühestens in sieben tagen darf
er sich frei testen das spiel gegen
augsburg hat er bereits verpasst
[Musik]
mehr informationen und hintergründe
finden sie außerdem wie immer online auf
zdf heute und jetzt andere nachrichten
sind unterlag aus
der grenzschutz von belarus hat nach
eigenen angaben die provisorischen
zeltlager tausende migranten an der eu
außengrenze zu polen geräumt der
polnische grenzschutz zeigt davon diese
bilder rund 2000 menschen seien in
notunterkünfte gebracht worden nur am
grenzübergang schnitzer campieren noch
einige hundert migranten offenbar
geduldet von belarussischen soldaten
weiterhin hoffen sie über polen in die
eu zu kommen
mehr als 400 iraker hatten das angebot
angenommen mit einer chartermaschine der
irakischen regierung in ihre heimat
zurückzufliegen
in kenia im us bundesstaat wisconsin ist
ein viel beachteter prozess mit einem
freispruch zu ende gegangen der
18-jährige der bei anti rassismus
protesten im vergangenen jahr zwei
menschen erschossen hatte habe in
notwehr gehandelt und sei nicht schuldig
so das urteil eines geschworenengerichts
auslöser der damaligen ausschreitungen
waren schüsse eines weißen polizisten in
den rücken eines afroamerikaners der
seither querschnittsgelähmt ist
nach den pannen bei der bundestagswahl
in berlin hat bundeswahlleiter thiel
einspruch gegen das ergebnis der
bundestagswahl in sechs berliner
wahlkreisen eingelegt dort mussten am 26
september zeitweise wahlräume
geschlossen werden weil stimmzettel
fehlten oder falsch waren dies könnte
auswirkungen auf die mandatsverteilung
gehabt haben aus dem gleichen grund hat
auch berlins innensenator geisel
einspruch gegen das ergebnis der
abgeordnetenhauswahl
eingelegt in beiden fällen wird nun
geprüft ob in den betroffenen bezirken
noch einmal gewählt wird
die gorch fock das segelschulschiff der
bundeswehr ist nach jahrelanger und
kostenintensive sanierung zu ersten
ausbildungsfahrt gestartet richtung
kanarische inseln in kiel wurde die 120
köpfige stammbesatzung von angehörigen
verabschiedet vor den kanaren will die
crew unter guten wetterbedingungen
trainieren zudem sollen
offiziersanwärter ausgebildet werden die
rückkehr in den heimathafen kiel ist für
ende märz geplant
millionen verbraucher sind von
steigenden strom- und gaspreisen
betroffen und müssen zum jahreswechsel
mit weiteren erhöhungen rechnen darauf
machen vergleichsportale und
verbraucherzentralen aufmerksam frank
bethmann wie begründen denn die
energieversorger die steigenden preise
ja vor allem mit den stark gestiegenen
beschaffungskosten dass die umstrittene
pipeline nord stream 2 wohl noch länger
kein gas aus russland liefern wird
wirkte zusätzlich preistreibend wurden
pandemie bedingt vergangenes jahr noch
im schnitt nur 9 euro 56 fällig sind es
in diesem jahr 38 eur 45 viermal so viel
bis heute mussten die grundversorger
etwaige preiserhöhungen für kommendes
jahr ankündigen
439 haben dies inzwischen getan nun
rufen die verbraucherverbände wieder auf
die chance zum anbieterwechsel zu nutzen
doch ebenso wichtig ist genau
nachzurechnen lohnt sich ein wechsel
wirklich energieexperten machen immerhin
hoffnung dass es an der preisfront bald
wieder besser werden könnte die märkte
erwarten eine sehr angespannte situation
für diesen winter und eine entspannung
dann also wir sehen das auch dass die
erdgaspreise danach fallen werden
allerdings so die einschätzung werden
sie nicht wieder auf das vor corinna
niveau sinken
wandbild man vielen dank wir haben ein
ganz aktuelles ergebnis aus der fußball
bundesliga bayern münchen ist corona
quarantäne bedingt etwas geschwächt am
abend beim fc augsburg angetreten und
tatsächlich gerade eben sehr schwer es
gewann der tabellenfünfzehnte augsburg 2
2 1 die sozialwissenschaftlerin irme
stetter karp ist neue präsidentin des
zentralkomitees der deutschen katholiken
dem wichtigsten verband katholischer
laien die vize-präsidentin des deutschen
caritasverbandes und co moderatorin des
synodalen weges kritisiert den
jahrzehntelangen reformstau in der
katholischen kirche die exklusion von
frauen von der weihe sei nicht
hinnehmbar
bundespräsident steinmeier ist in new
york mit der leo baeck medaille
ausgezeichnet worden für sein engagement
für jüdisches leben in deutschland
steinmeier sprechen mit großer
moralischer klarheit so der präsident
des jüdischen weltkongresses lauda und
das in einer zeit in der zu viele staats
und regierungschefs schwiegen in seiner
dankesrede würdigte steinmeier das
wunder der versöhnung zugleich warnte er
vor den gefahren durch zunehmenden
antisemitismus in deutschland
das war es von uns ist folgen die heute
show und dann übermannt und um 0.18
meldet sich hier nah sagte mir mit
unserem heute-journal update es morgen
wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen schönes
wochenende
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter der hohen luftdruck der
schwindelte allmähliche und das nutzt
ein tief und zieht von norden weiter
südwärts bringt dann morgen abend zu
etwas regen von norden her aber es
bleibt dennoch nicht trocken es gibt
sprühregen aus der dichten bewölkung und
das auch in der kommenden nacht vor
allem hier über der mitte nach norden
hin ist es eher trocken aber an den
küsten weht ein kräftiger teils
stürmischer westwind teils auch
nordwestwind richtung ostsee ganz im
süden haben es mit nebel zu tun und an
den alpen da klart es teilweise auf und
dann gehen die temperaturen runter bis
auf minus zwei grad am kältesten
sonst haben wir es zweistelligen werten
zu tun nach norden mit zehn bis elf grad
morgen dann wieder im norden viele
wolken und hier und da etwas sprühregen
an den küsten weiterhin windig aus west
teils stürmisch ganz im süden zeigt sich
auch mal die sonne vor allem über den
bergen im südwesten kann sich der nebel
auflösen wenn das passiert dann gibt es
auch sonst ein ansonsten bleibt es dicht
temperaturen dazu mit höchsten werten
von 5 grad am alpenrand sonst liegen die
werte ganz im norden bei elf bis zwölf
grad also deutlich milder als im süden
die nächsten tage am sonntag kommt der
regen allmählich weiter südwärts voran
ganz im süden ist durchaus sonnenschein
noch dabei bei vier bis elf grad am
montag wird es kühler werden aber dafür
im norden sonnig temperaturen drei bis
acht grad und vor allem nach südosten
hin ziemlich dicht bewölkt ja und am
dienstag ist es etwas kälter bei 1 bis 9
grad damit ein schöner abend